well mr president
dear joe again we are very pleased to
welcome you in brussels to welcome your
delegations we are delighted to have
this opportunity today
to tackle very important global
challenges we think in fact we have
three priorities the first one we need
to promote
our common democratic values this is a
fundamental challenge
we are on the same page we need not only
to react
we need to act proactively the student
point is certainly the prosperity how is
it possible to support
more prosperity in the world it means
that we need to tackle
climate change the digital ambition the
digital transformation but also
to defeat profit 19 and to support
more recovery after this 10 days
and the third point probably is the
security and the stability
in the world and that's why we are so so
pleased to cooperate with you
in order to to guarantee more
predictability more stability
and more security in one word
america is back we are we are pleased we
are
delighted because we are confident we
know that
we will work together we will uh not
only renew
this fundamental alliance transatlantic
alliance
will also work in order to strengthen uh
this robust
alliance it's a very warm welcome from
my side too
mr president dear job um we're really
honored and it's a great pleasure to
have you here in brussels
and indeed that you're coming so early
in your mandate
i think underline strongly the personal
attachment
you have for europe and this is
something we really highly appreciate
um in we have been speaking about the
fact that
um the last four years were not easy
and that the world changed dramatically
and europe has changed
but it is for us very important to
reassure you
that we are your friends and it's
wonderful to have you as friends back
here
we are allies we share the same values
we share the same interests we have the
same world view
and we're aware that we need to team up
and join up to tackle the big challenges
we have ahead of us so from our side a
very very warm welcome
to brussels and to europe thank you both
very much uh
it's been one of the great pleasures uh
getting to know you both uh
more personally than just in terms of
our official positions
and we're at the g7 and again today i
apologize i
kept my colleagues in the
closed meeting but um i want to uh
um you know this is uh i haven't been
back to brussels uh
the eu since uh 2017
and uh since the back then
also the first summit back in 2014
for me but i brought the a-team with me
today and um you know i've said both
publicly and privately
that america is back and which is why
we're here in full force
i'm happy to have with me today the
members of my cabinet
secretary of state anthony blinken he
suffers from the problem of having
worked with me for years
and and also trade representative
ambassador
catherine ty who has made some real
progress already
and secretary of commerce gina ramundo
who was a
first-rate governor and one of the
brightest people
that we've worked with and uh and agreed
to come on as
as our secretary of commerce and uh
one of the things that uh i've you and i
were talking about will come as no shock
to either of you
europe is uh is uh our our
natural partner and the reason is we're
committed to the same democratic norms
and institutions
that are uh and they are increasingly
under attack
and uh we i've said before and i
apologize for repeating oh i didn't
i jake sullivan you know jake is my nasa
security advisor
i'm leaving out a lot of people here i
apologize i'm going to get in trouble
but
anyway we'll get back to that but um
uh we um
you know there's a lot that uh
that is is is happening i used to always
uh my friends would uh
kid me uh in the united states senate
the years i served there for
always quoting irish poets i think i
quoted irish post because i'm irish
that's not the reason i quote them
because they're the best poets in the
world that's why
but all kidding aside um there's a
there's a stanza from a poem of an irish
poet who was
just lost he said all's changed
changed utterly a terrible beauty has
been born
i think all has changed in the last uh
10 12 years and it's not because of any
one person
i think we're in the midst of a terrible
beauty having been born a great
shift in
technology a great shift in development
of the world and it's causing great
anxiety
in each of our countries and uncertainty
among
many of our colleagues is what's going
to be their place in the world
they're going to be replaced by new
technology are they going to
no longer have a job what are they going
to do
and that that comes along at the same
time that
that also generates when uncertainty is
generated politically like that about
individuals
it also generates some folks who are
less than
how can i say it somewhat more like
charlatans
trying to take advantage of those
concerns and we see in europe we see in
the united states we've seen it
around the world this phony populism so
it seems to me
that the best answer to deal with
these changes is that uh
to have a circumstance where
our economies grow and they grow
together
and they grow still based on the value
set that united us in the first place
and i think we do share just the same
basic values of
human dignity human rights as i my
colleagues i'll be very
colloquial with you my dad
had a transition where in uh
in the city we lived in cole was dying
and no longer relevant he oh he was not
a
my great grandfather was a
a coal miner he was a mining engineer
but
when in northeastern pennsylvania when
cole died my dad was a salesperson
and the economy collapsed and we moved
to another part where there were jobs
and southern into
down in delaware at the very just across
the pennsylvania border
and my family my siblings and i would
hear him all
often use the following expression he'd
say joe a job's about a lot more than a
paycheck
it's about your dignity it's about
respect
it's about your place in the community
it's about being able to look your child
in the eye and say honey is going to be
okay
and mean it i think we sometimes forget
that
it's about the dignity of the worker and
them being able to hold their head high
and so i think we have an enormous
opportunity
if we think in terms of these changes
particularly in terms of global warming
if we think of in terms of jobs the kind
of jobs that we're going to have to
create to preserve the environment
are jobs that can pay well that
are going to be new technologies that
working class
blue collar workers as we say in the
states or began to make more money
be able to do well and but we have to
all of us accommodate those changes and
provide for them
and so i think we have a lot
to deal with from cover 19 to
the to whether or not we're in a
position that we can
generate the kind of you know
strengthening transatlantic trade and
technological
cooperation they're sort of a different
set of priorities
with the same objective how do
like-minded countries
sharing the same values
work together to improve the living
standard for not only
our people but for the rest of the world
and i think we have the capacity to do
that it's going to take
an awful lot of hard work and
determination
and i'll conclude by saying one of the
reasons i'm optimistic is because of our
younger generations
in europe as well as the united states
the young generation this one is the
best educated in american history
it is also the least prejudice the most
open and the most the most committed
and i think that we have reason to
believe that
if we provide the policies that are
consistent to provide for the kind of
growth and opportunity for them
and education plays a gigantic part of
that i think we
i think the future is very very bright i
think we have an opportunity
to do some really very good things and
with that i should as my mother would
say i should hush
up and let this discussion move forward